how have you been keeping yourselves
busy um because i know a lot of people
have
you know while being sick at home we've
kind of started new things i've toddlers
so i've started calling i never thought
i'd be one of those adults coloring in
those adult coloring books
well little did i know the pandemic
would bring that to light because
i i'm done drawing jasmine i can't draw
i can't color another jasmine
so i'm sorry have you all started doing
anything
amazing joey you you've been killing it
i've been watching her so jealous gone
i um i started i started doing dioramas
um i've taken what it's like okay so you
know like little like like little house
models like little like
models of like mini scape so i made like
a mini library like last month that took
me three weeks to make
and um that was so weird fun
yeah i have a photo of it okay it's so
it was so fun and i just i loved it so
much and i just bought a little kit to
make a diorama coffee shop
so that you know this is my this is my
library
oh my gosh oh my gosh
well okay i haven't done that but my
kids have just recently gotten into
legos they're four and six so i've
started building little things like that
like little
but that is crazy hard oh my gosh it is
it was so hard it took me so and then
the the instructions
they're great but they're kind of more
of like a loose like suggestion of how
to make it
i'm like i don't know what i'm doing but
it was so fun maisie what about you
well it's kind of funny because since i
was about 4 till
15 i had this dream of having a farm and
being a farmer and it was just like this
obsession this dream of like
you know i'm just going to grow my own
produce raise my own animals so i was
like right i've got some time i'm going
to start some gardening i'm going to do
this
so i planted spinach i planted okra i
did
vegetables everything and nothing grew
oh
i love them the only thing i grew was my
sunflower because apparently it's a weed
i didn't know
and that's my favorite flower exactly if
i had this one little flower
i named it kelly oh my gosh that's
amazing
that's so cool subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going